merci Monsieur monsieur le Premier
ministre je voulais vous demander votre
soutien à la demande de grâce
présidentielle formulée par les fil
jaceline sauvage et avec le concours de
maître thomasini est soutenu par de
nombreux parlementaires vous le savez
Jacqueline sauvage est le symbole
français des 134 femmes qui sont
décédées en 2014 sous les coups de leur
maris violent mais actualité oblige
comment ne pas réagir aux inquiétants
événements qui se déroulent en Europe
les autorités allemandes on plus de 600
plaintes pour injure agression sexuelle
et viol pour la seule ville de Cologne
le soir du nouvel an c'est grâce aux
informations circulant sur Internet que
les langues des autorités se sont enfin
déliées il a fallu attendre plusieurs
jours pour que l'on apprennent que ces
agressions ont été coordonnées et
perpétré par des étrangers et des
migrants accueillis par milliers en
Allemagne en Suède on nous a cacher viol
et agression dans les mêmes
circonstances mais attention pas
d'amalgame plutôt que de condamner avec
la plus grande fermeté ces actes odieux
on les cache et on demande même aux
femmes d'adapter leur tenu et leur
comportement c'est évident que si elles
se sont faites agresser de leurs faute
elles l'ont bien cherché à la lumière de
ces événements comment ne pas être
choqué par le manque de réaction des
autorités européennes où sont les
féministes sommes-nous en train
d'assister à l'avènement d'une nouvelle
forme de terrorisme un terrorisme sexuel
où l'on considère les femmes comme du
gibier les Français sont inquiets après
les statistiques de l'Organisation
internationale pour l'immigration pour
2015 70 % des migrants sont des hommes
en grande majorité jeunes savons-nous
pourquoi on accueille majoritairement
des hommes et pas des familles que
deviennent leurs familles en France
qu'en est-il ces questions sont cement
dérangeantes elles sont choquantes mais
il serait irresponsable de ne pas les
aborder avec franchise et transparence
monsieur le Premier ministre nous
aspirons tous à vivre dans une France
apaisée à l'heure où vous répartissez
les migrants dans nos villes et nos
campagnes pouvez-vous nous dire quelles
mesures sont prises concrètement pour
que leur accueil se passe au mieux merci
la parole est à Madame Pascale Boitard
secrétaire d'État chargé du droit des
femmes des droits des
femmes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Boyer votre question mélange
des sujets
terribles mais font aussi beaucoup
d'amalgam je rappelle que le viol est
dans notre pays considéré comme un
crime
et il ne m'appartient pas ici de me
substituer à mon homologue
allemande par contre et vous l'avez vous
l' vous ne l'avez pas dit dans votre
dans votre question évidemment toutes
les femmes et tous les hommes qui
défendent les droits des femmes et qui
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes sur ses bancs et aussi ailleurs
se sont ému de cette
situation et je crois que ces moments
aussi difficiles pour plusieurs
centaines de femmes sont aussi des
moments pour nous ici en France de nous
dire que ce gouvernement qui a fait une
priorité de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes de renforcer
aussi ce crime qui est le viol qui
arrive aux femmes encore trop souvent
dans notre pays et bien c'est notre
détermination qui fera que ces violences
reculeront encore dans notre pays alors
soyez à nos côtés au niveau européen
pour obtenir encore une stratégie
européenne sur les droits des femmes
pour lutter contre les violences qui
sont faites aux femmes en Europe parce
qu'aujourd'hui et bien nous avons besoin
de tout le monde pour obtenir et bien
que les droits des femmes avancent sur
l'Europe merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Yv durant